we're halfway through 2020 and let's  face it it's good but if there's  anything that's been keeping us all  together its video games and thankfully  there's been a lot of damn good ones  this year so far so we here at GameSpot  put together a list of the 20 amazing  games of 2020 so far  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  and there you have it the most amazing  games so far of this totally way I could  do year and to think we're only halfway  through it but that just means on the  bright side we still have like a ton  more games to look forward to and new  consoles of course let us know in the  comments if we missed one and in the  meantime equal you well play video games  and be nice to each other all right  thanks for coming by see you later  [Music]  you